si discrète et pourtant si symbolique
niché dans la petite chapelle de la
vierge à l'intérieur de la collégiale
la voici posé sur son coussin jean paul
ii l'avait remise un jeune séminariste
de montrésor devenu depuis bénédictins
lemoine a été dans l'obligation de se
déposséder de tous ses biens
il a donc décidé de la confier à la
paroisse c'est une pratique qui avait
été oubliée par les parcs qui ont
succédé à pline 12 je crois mais du
temps de pie xii
il ne pouvait pas déplacé sans passer
une calotte est notre lot et tout le
monde lui offrait des calottes et donc
il y avait pléthore de reliques de ce
type là pour jean paul ii jean paul ii
était beaucoup plus frugale
on va dire et surtout la tradition avait
été perdu et ce jeune moine lui il
n'avait pas oublié grâce à ça on en a eu
ni presque unique au monde c'est raulic
fait partie des quatre calotte que le
pape jean paul 2 a donné au cours de son
pontificat
c'est un élément qui va permettre de
fixer l'attention d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui viendra montrésor et
peut-être feront le détour pour voir
quelque chose qui est assez rare je vous
annonce tout de suite que le reliquaire
est totalement inviolable parfaitement
sécurisée et c'est donc là il est là en
sécurité en parallèle un autre trésor de
la collégiale est en train de retrouver
son éclat
le retable de la chapelle de la vierge
qui depuis plusieurs semaines et sous
les mains expertes de deux
restauratrices spécialisés le but
c'était le désencrasser de reprendre les
petits accidents qui était trop visible
au niveau de ce qu'est de colonnes nous
avions un boudin qui étaient peints
sculptés qui était parti et donc nous
avons repris à l'enduit cette zone nous
avons repassé un glacis d'offres dessus
quelques pointes dorures et impôts de
patine mais le but n'était pas de faire
un moulage et de refaire leur à 9
c'était vraiment justement de garder cet
esprit discret le 1er mai prochain la
calotte de jean paul ii sera
officiellement béni lors d'un office
dominical qui célébrera par la même
occasion le cinquième anniversaire de la
béatification de jean paul ii